hello and welcome to this video and see
what can do again kusja we one advantage
of having such a direct rating as you
get other opponents and I'm actually
making this mistake oh my god the
mistake is strong with its old main line
of the bangko which is not very correct
it seems ok it doesn't play therefore
line then sets good news on this 1284
with nine on f3 so i get a fairly
regular bank owned well I don't really
know this particular line because i
usually avoid it by not playing Bishop a
six-foot ok if I made this basically
mouth slip
bit off-putting am Bishop g5 sometimes
you can recover this technically but
okay if I start to think about stuff
like that i'm going to lose every game
on time train queens him and i will know
what to yeah so I'm a pawn down in this
banco ending but how bad is that you
cannot go a form still not and what am I
going to do here with my night and i
would like to neck or place your phone
anyway maybe just try to go to d3 is
good d 3d form yeah looks like looks
very logical actually ok bishop detune i
also have f5 sometimes but i think here
this is good Bishop see three years that
is idea
you should see 3m maybe I'm not sure
then if I want to go night before but
should take group cheeks could it could
be enough for the poem but and why can I
not take this what am i overlooking here
[Music]
ok show me I was really never possible
we see claiming that the pawn is very
dangerous now I don't really believe it
let's see can I win this pawns on huh
and now i'm going to five undermining
the center wait i can also check and I
have this check here look everyone King
III though if I take it Kim tags do I
have a tactic there maybe don't see it
at the moment okay so let's play a
strategic move after the capture is d5
own is severely weakened and I'm
thinking of night be two nights if form
if possible winning the air palm
now that looks looks quite sensible even
night before takes pawn takes looks good
I can go b3 b2 doesn't feel doesn't feel
bad Adam the night only to it really has
some pretty awful piece that looks good
I don't really see anything great that
he can do Knight c3 I could have
probably taken so is G 4 I mean I can
make just as I can just do that check
check and to know
maybe this wait is he going to f5 and
try to get counterplay mm okay i can go
here
so anyway to plate to Pluto plate to
play against this king I don't know but
this this should should really do the
trick the B point is really extremely
dangerous and he has to take more or
less otherwise i'll just 85 to take that
into account at all okay now g5 coming
up but I can take I can take the Reliant
the night chick has check you're telling
me 93 s not winning not entirely sure
how easy this is actually it looks great
but maybe it's not not that easy for
example if i play night time where I'm
not sure at all how do I do that here
hmm and this isn't easy it just isn't
don't see where to put this the night I
mean he cannot currently attack it
though not easily a night a bishop trade
should be winning try to come around
here be 786 that it's it's not this much
this must be a winner that would be
quite weird if not
97
[Music]
yeah had to go back and now I'm coming
around there with the King I think check
I have to see that he's not sacrificing
everything oh that wins another pawn
check okay quite resigned oh my with my
life really difficult down from from a
very good position yeah well okay in the
opening alright and alyssa's view on the
hotel oh my god I kind of offer you
everything yeah anyway so I should
switch it on at least so yeah be sure
basics of course this is the normal move
here or a normal move the whole term
main line in a way that I do I play this
and it's just a different line and now
I'm stuck in something that I really
don't want to have on the board the
problematic line is is this one not this
one this one where black has huge
problems so it's something that I avoid
with the other move water okay you
played a different setup and well I just
played like the normal looking moves
king at a time not sure about it looks a
bit strange yeah now this one and other
thing I was happy that the Queen sketch
rated T actually this seems reasonable
he cannot easily play a form always do
to locate form and I felt I could have
enough compensation 9053 those ideas
computer always lags wide that's a very
very normal in the bank owned 93 yeah
and he played a for which just doesn't
work yeah I expected a move like f3
let's say and then we continue from here
one idea is actually what the engine
s f5 this is an interesting resource
that wasn't so well known to me before I
started to study in the vanco wear this
black often is able to undermine wide
center so exam for example if he takes
this pawn is going to be a weakness
interesting yeah maybe the engine is
right that like it's slightly worse but
I'm not not sure the other computer
actually wants to play this and then
this position yeah that looks a bit
better maybe then the game here my
activity was extremely annoying and fire
for the typical way to do it here Andrew
k 3 is stronger yeah I felt like I can't
keep it simple check but it probably
didn't make it simpler in fact or okay
one just wins everything okay yeah I was
tempted was just tempted to take the
palm finally be a pawn up but UK one is
not exactly difficult he has no more Sam
down like here so crazy pinning pinning
game the NTA it continues and maybe it
is winning many it's not i'm fairly sure
it is a winner after the trade of the
bishops Oh c4 was easier winning the
bishop okay yeah i think this should be
a win ok guys thanks for watching